[Aplausos]
la única mujer xiomara castró del
partido de izquierda libertad y
refundación afianzó su liderazgo las
protestas por el golpe de estado contra
su esposo manuel zelaya se postula por
segunda vez con la idea de sacar del
poder a lo que llama la dictadura del
partido nacional generará las
oportunidades para que no tengan los
hondureños y hondureñas que a salir del
país salen porque no encuentran
poder cambiar una calidad de vida por su
parte el empresario gianni rosental del
partido liberal ha prometido beneficiar
a unos 5 millones de hondureños con un
bono mensual de 62 dólares en el 2017
fue sentenciado a 36 meses de prisión en
nueva york tras declararse culpable por
lavado de activos regresó al país luego
de cumplir tres años en prisión el
ingreso básico universal
es
de mil quinientos lempiras mensuales
para todos los hondureños mayores de 18
años
entretanto el actual alcalde de la
capital el empresario nasry asfura con
su discurso anti aborto por familia y la
propia reducir las cifras de desempleo
apela mantener en el poder al
oficialista partido nacional que ha
gobernado en los últimos 12 años con
algunos de sus dirigentes salpicados por
escándalos de corrupción y otros
acusados y sentenciados en tribunales de
nueva york por supuesto vínculos con el
narcotráfico pero dándole oportunidades
de trabajo a la gente ese es mi
compromiso eso lo que ha aprendido
[Aplausos]
buscándole oportunidad y es solo mi mamá
el nuevo presidente o presidenta de
honduras se enfrentará a grandes
desafíos el principal detener las
masivas caravanas de migrantes que salen
rumbo a eeuu pero para ello debe
recuperar una economía golpeada por la
pandemia y los desastres naturales